was a mastermind of fear and brutality
he helped osama bin laden turn al-qaeda
into a global network of terror from the
safe haven of afghanistan when it was
first under taliban control
he's really been at the helm of jihad
for
at least 40 years if not 50 years
so
he's he's got that whole cocktail of
respectable qualities what he really
lacks
is the kind of charisma that
osama bin laden had i think he lacks an
ability to
attract a new young generation
working together the pair unleashed
carnage on the u.s embassies in tanzania
and kenya
horror on the uss coal off the coast of
yemen
and then the bloodiest attack of them
all against new york and washington on
the 11th of september 2001.
the atrocities made this egyptian doctor
one of the most wanted terrorists on the
planet along with the then al-qaeda
chief bin laden
both men had 25 million dollar bounties
on their heads
when bin laden was finally found and
killed in 2011 zawahiri was his obvious
successor
but he lacked the same visionary appeal
and al-qaeda's ability to control the
actions of an array of terror franchises
faulted
the rise of rival group islamic state
also posed a challenge
that said last year's u.s withdrawal
from afghanistan did throw al qaeda a
lifeline
a resurgent taliban appears willing to
offer the group a haven in defiance of
u.s demands
yet it's hard to imagine whoever takes
over from zawahiri will achieve the same
level of notoriety as he did with bin
laden those in the running include
egyptian militant safe al-adha abdul
rathman al-mughrabi from morocco or one
of the leaders of two al-qaeda
affiliates yazid mubarak or ahmed durie
it does close the chapter on this
particular expression of the kind of
terrorist threat but you know terrorism
unfortunately is a concept and as a
practice has been around for a very long
time what we've seen is that it tends to
morph into new directions and
unfortunately that's probably what we're
going to see now
taking out the leader of a terrorist
group is clearly a key moment
but it's no long-term fix
debra haynes sky news